I have a great documentary
recommendation for you today it's a
strange name okay the film is called
pervert Park to 2014 documentary it is
on netflix it is also on amazon pervert
park is the nickname for a it's called a
florida justice transitions trailer park
and what this is is a place where former
uh sex offenders convicted sex offenders
about a hundred of them are allowed to
live and as you may know it's it can be
sometimes difficult when disclosing that
you're a convicted sex offender to
secure housing so the the idea of
pervert park is its colloquially
nicknamed is that convicted sex
offenders after the release from prison
i can show up here and they can live and
the film is endlessly fascinating and
they interview sex offenders uh of
different levels and you have some
individuals who are uh have been
convicted of violent sexual acts against
kids and then you have some individuals
that were really just caught up in
online dating stings were the idea of
being with someone that was legally
unable to consent was sort of thrown in
almost as an aside and they really feel
like they were the victims of entrapment
so that's one interesting aspect sort of
the difference in terms of the people
that are labeled for their entire lives
in the united states as convicted sex
offenders but those there's also a lot
of discussion because in the film pat
they show these sort of like fit group
therapy uh sessions where people who
have been sort of living at at pervert
park for a long time are sort of in a
way counseling or mentoring people who
are more recently out in the real world
and the conversations that they have in
some cases suggest to me this is clearly
something that can be controlled and the
idea that child predator set sex
predators can never control their urges
it feels like it's not true but then you
hear from some of the other individuals
they talk to you say that is not someone
that should ever be around children for
the rest of their lives yes an
interesting topic because when you
registered as a sex offender there's so
many places where you can't live near
part
near schools you have to think after
that where they going to be able to put
these people and this is a big debate in
terms of is this something that you can
be to use a sort of crude term cured of
or is it not it's a debate in the mental
health community to debate in the law
enforcement and legal community and the
film is very very eye-opening pervert
park it's on Netflix it's on Amazon and
you can check out all of my
recommendations at david pakman.com
slash recommendations remember the
indiegogo campaign is on at david
pakman.com slash donate working to
really scale up progressive media and
progressive activism in a coordinated
way check it out donate what you can
david pakman.com slash donate